Speaker 1: Hey, among all of this bad stuff
going on, let me talk briefly about something
really exciting.
We're approaching one billion.
That's with a B one billion YouTube views.
You might remember that last September, right
around September 15th, fourteenth, twelfth,
something like that, we hit an important milestone,
one million YouTube subscriptions, one million
YouTube subscribers.
We are now already almost 40 percent.
Beyond that, we're almost at one point four
million subscribers.
We've seen 40 percent subscriber growth in
the last 11 months.
It's incredible.
But now we're moving on to views.
You can have tons of subscriptions all over
the place.
But if those people aren't watching your videos,
it's basically worth nothing.
And some channels have that situation.
Millions of subscribers, almost no views.
We are now approaching a billion YouTube views.
Listen to how nuts the growth is.
Last year at this time, our entire channel
had six hundred million views.
The last four hundred million views are coming
and basically one year, which is insane.
And I have only you to thank for that.
We are now at nine hundred eighty nine million
views.
That's about ten and a half million away from
one billion.
Now, how long is this going to take?
We often get a million views in a day, but
not every day.
So it could be nine days.
If we had a really strong nine days, more
likely it would be something like two to two
and a half weeks.
So what are we doing for this?
First of all, we're putting together a fantastic
billion view compilation with a nice counter
rolling up to a billion.
It's going to start with old clips and go
all the way through.
There's going to be classics in there that
many of our newer viewers and listeners may
never have seen.
So we're putting that together.
It's going to be like an eight or nine minute
long clip producer that's been doing a great
job with it.
And it's going to be ready.
It'll.
Be ready to be triggered by us surpassing
one billion views.
That's number one.
Number two, yes, there's going to be a huge
membership special at one billion.
Of course there is.
You better believe it.
We are going to blow membership's out of here
like you wouldn't believe, like nobody's ever
seen before.
In fact, just get on my newsletter at David
Pakman dot com to be notified.
There's no specific date because we don't
know when we're going to hit the billion.
And then number three, we want this.
We've never tried this before.
OK, here, this is just an idea.
We want to try to make a compilation of people
from the audience calling in to other shows.
They can be left wing shows or right wing
shows and somehow mentioning David Pakman
show YouTube, one billion views.
It can be just like a you call a friendly
show.
And you might mention, hey, will you be congratulating
The David Pakman Show on a billion views?
It can be trolling of right wing shows, whatever.
The only thing is just David Pakman show a
billion views mentioned during a Call-In on
other shows.
Send them in if you're able to do it.
I know many of you are regular callers to
all sorts of different shows.
Can we get it in front of Mike Lyndell?
Can we get him?
Who knows?
Dan Bongino with all these people?
Charlie SPORCK and then send us a link.
We'll compile it together and hopefully have
a funny video in addition to our Billion View
compilation for you.
By the I mean, it really should be early in
September, could even maybe be in August.
So we'll keep you updated.
We are at nine eighty nine million on the
way to one billion